Chile is a South American
wilderness.
Isolated from the rest
of the continent,
the country is a mosaic
of different landscapes.
(music)
None are quite as hostile
as the Atacama Desert.
(music)
These are thirsty lands.
Some areas haven't seen rain
since history books began.
It's the driest desert
on Earth,
where water has to be salvaged
from unusual sources.
Risk is an everyday reality.
Creatures in Chile's
Atacama Desert adapt or die.
(music)
The Atacama is one of the most
unforgiving places on Earth.
(music)
Stretching across
northern Chile,
and straddling four countries,
the Atacama Desert is
almost as big as Cuba.
Other than Earth's poles,
no other place in the world
is drier than here.
The wettest areas receive only
half an inch of rain a year.
But in the desert's center,
as far as history knows,
it has never rained.
Every corner of the compass
reveals nothing but sand,
stretching as far
as the eye can see.
(music)
It seems impossible that
anything can live here.
(music)
Despite the bleak
prospects of life,
if you know how,
there are ways of surviving.
The animals of the Atacama
never overlook opportunity.
And when they find it,
they fight to the death
to defend it.
(music)
In the middle of the Atacama,
life congregates around
any source of water.
(music)
The Salar de Atacama is
the largest salt flat in Chile.
Its waters are filtered down
from the Andes
almost 200 miles to the east.
With no way to escape
the mountain plateau,
the waters are trapped.
They slowly evaporate,
leaving behind a vast expanse
of thick salt crust.
It's here that the Atacama is
host to a salt flat fighter.
At the lake's edge,
the Fabian's lizard is king.
There's not much to rule over,
but whatever there is,
he'll defend with
unrestrained ferocity.
And he doesn't do it alone.
An unusual and
ingenious lizard,
he would be nothing
without his partner in crime.
This female is his honey trap.
Her job is to distract invading
males with sexual pheromones,
allowing her mate to ambush
the unsuspecting intruder.
They use the highest salt crust
as a look out.
From here they can
survey their land
and spot any would-be usurpers.
(music)
It isn't long before
a trespasser catches their eye.
(music)
The scaly temptress
wastes no time
before flirting with the enemy.
(music)
He's enticed by her advances,
but of course,
it's too good to be true.
Her partner spies on them
from a distance,
waiting for the perfect moment.
A signal from her,
and he charges into battle.
He puffs himself out
to intimidate his competitor,
but his rival's no coward.
The two salt flat fighters
go for the kill.
(music)
(hissing)
After countless throw downs,
the intruder is
desperate to escape.
But this lizard's forte
is fighting.
(hissing)
(music)
(hiss)
Finally, the intruder
is allowed to leave,
a little battered and bruised.
The couple have a good reason
for defending this patch.
(buzzing)
Their main source of food
is swarming.
In the heat of the day,
black clouds of flies
descend on the water's edge.
For the lizards,
catching them is an art form.
(music)
But this isn't the case
for everyone.
This Andean lapwing's methods
are a little less
sophisticated.
(music)
There's little else to eat,
but there are plenty of flies
to go around.
(music)
What little life exists here
has been isolated
for a long time.
It's had to adapt to the
hostile climate of the Atacama.
The waters here have
a similar salt concentration
to the Dead Sea.
Too high to sustain much,
but what there is
entices the desert's
most flamboyant residents.
(squawking)
Flamingoes.
These birds wear pink,
but they're no
delicate dancers.
Everything about them
is tailored
to counter
the punishing conditions.
They've spent 30 million years
biologically evolving
to the demands of life.
They're specially adapted
to these brackish waters.
Flamingoes are one
of the few animals on Earth
that are able
to drink the water.
(music)
Just because
they can cope here
doesn't mean that life's easy
for Chile's flamingoes.
In the early afternoon heat
the air in the Atacama
grows restless.
The rising temperatures
create dust devils
that churn their way
across the landscape
at speeds of
up to 45 miles per hour.
A reminder of just how
unwelcome life is
in the Atacama Desert.
The conditions
of the Atacama Desert
are more similar
to the surface of Mars
than anywhere else on Earth.
So much so,
that NASA comes here
to help unlock the secrets
of the Red Planet.
This desert is
50 times more arid
than California's Death Valley.
As well as being the driest
desert in the world,
the Atacama is also
one of the oldest.
It hasn't changed much
in 150 million years.
Bacteria in the soils
of the Atacama
could hold the key to the
beginning of planetary life.
(music)
In the middle of the desert
this lagoon is home
to one of the oldest forms
of life on Earth.
(music)
These stromatolite structures
are made from layer upon layer
of very simple bacteria.
Life on Earth as we know it
owes its existence
to these modest-looking lumps.
(music)
It's this bacteria that
first introduced oxygen
into the planet's atmosphere
allowing life on Earth
to explode.
The waters of the lagoon
reveal more of the world's
ancient life-forms.
Triops.
These little creatures are one
of the oldest animal species
still in existence.
Unchanged for more than
70 million years.
They're born survivors,
able to withstand
very warm alkaline waters.
(music)
Today, these skills are evident
in the Atacama's
other inhabitants.
More than merely
salt lake experts,
flamingoes are one of the few
animals able to withstand
the caustic soda found
in the desert's thermal pools.
Chile is home to more than
300 geothermal fields.
Spots where heat from deep
within the molten earth
can be felt on the surface.
Most of them can be found
in the Atacama.
Some are more noticeable
than others.
(music)
More than 80 geysers are dotted
throughout the desert.
Chile's most famous are
the El Tatio geysers.
It's the biggest
cluster of geysers
in the Southern Hemisphere,
and the third largest on Earth.
Located 14,000 feet
above sea level,
they belong to the highest
geothermal field in the world.
(music)
At these altitudes, water is
a little easier to come by
than in the desert's
heartlands.
Snowmelt from
the nearby mountains
collects and forms small lakes
on the Altiplano.
At this altitude
there are strange creatures
that call the water pools home.
The giant coot
lives up to its name.
This water bird
weighs five pounds.
(music)
Huge feet allow them to carry
their bulk over floating weeds
without sinking.
This male is looking
for building material.
Giant coots are house proud.
Their entire day is dedicated
to constructing their nest.
They work together
with their partners,
spending hours adding
to the structure
with plants they've torn up
from the lakebed.
(squawking)
(music)
There's a lot at stake
for these homeowners.
Trespassing isn't tolerated.
Yet some coots aren't willing
to put in the time
to do their own
home improvements.
(music)
Nest-looting in this
neighborhood is rife.
(music)
Enough's enough.
This coot isn't having it.
He sets his sights
on the latest thief
and charges after him.
Giant coots can't really fly.
But their incredibly
powerful legs
and huge crab-like feet
allow them to blaze
through the water.
(music)
(squawking)
When the homeowner
catches up with the thief,
he initiates the coot version
of kickboxing.
(music)
Though this might look silly,
there's a lot of power
behind each slap.
The claws on the end
of the coots' feet
are incredibly sharp.
In the chaos of the fight,
they've trespassed onto
another neighbor's territory.
(music)
The fight has now escalated
into a brawl.
(music)
(squawking)
Finally, exhausted,
everyone cools off.
(shrieking)
But the peace will definitely
be short-lived
with tempers like these.
As the sun sets,
shadows in Chile's Altiplano
stretch their way up
the banks of the Andes.
Meanwhile in the desert's
dry and dusty interior,
an unlikely animal
remains wide awake.
In the middle of Chile's
Atacama Desert,
the skies are clear
nearly 24 hours a day.
Even clouds don't venture
into the seemingly
desolate wasteland.
And because of their absence,
temperatures at night
are near freezing.
It's now that
one of the Atacama's
most surprising inhabitants
must draw on some
serious fortitude
to get through the night.
(peeping)
The gray gull nests here
in the desert.
(squawk)
Make no mistake,
these are seabirds.
For years no one knew
where these seemingly ordinary
birds went to nest.
Then they were stumbled upon
in 1945,
here in the driest desert
in the world.
(peeping)
But these gulls aren't lost.
This is actually
a perfect example
of the ingenuity
of the Atacama's animals.
They could be here because
there are barely any predators.
In that sense, it's the perfect
spot to raise a family.
But that perk comes
with several catches.
The parents must take turns
traveling more than 60 miles
to the coast to collect food
and water for their chicks.
Daytime brings
even more challenges.
As the temperature rises,
these eggs could cook
in the baking hot soils.
In the hottest part of the day,
the parent on duty
must stand over the eggs,
keeping them in the shade.
It's a selfless act
in these temperatures.
But the gulls are
well adjusted to life here.
The colors of their feathers
are thought to be
an adaptation,
enabling them to radiate heat.
Even the eggs are well designed
for the desert.
Their hard, impervious shell
means little moisture
evaporates from inside the egg.
In fact, 30% less than some
other desert nesting birds.
(peeping)
(squawk)
When they're old enough,
the chicks take turns
giving each other shade.
(peeping)
But mom always makes
a better sunshield.
Some don't survive
this perilous start to life.
But those that do
won't wait long
before making their first
pilgrimage to the shore.
(music)
After around 40 days
and 40 nights in the desert,
gray gull chicks finally fledge
and follow their parents
to the ocean.
The eastern edge of the Pacific
awaits them.
(music)
At the midway mark
of the Atacama's coastline,
the desert is littered
with boulders and rocks.
(music)
Here the sea batters the shore
with furious waves,
often 25 feet tall.
(music)
Despite the odds,
it's on this turbulent border
that the Atacama Pacific iguana
has made a successful
enterprise.
Like its name suggests,
this lizard bridges the gap
between desert and ocean.
They're another of
the Atacama's unusual lizards.
But like all reptiles, they're
pretty lazy in the morning.
They begin the day
with a bit of sunbathing
to raise their metabolism.
(music)
They need all the energy they
can get for what's in store.
As the sun rises
and low tide approaches,
Pacific lizards begin
checking the ocean.
(music)
Climbing to a higher point,
they can survey the water.
They're not here
out of curiosity.
(music)
They know all too well
what the water can do.
These lizards are not
built for swimming,
and they stand no chance
in these waves.
That's why what they do next
is so surprising.
These rocks are covered
in nutrient-rich algae,
a veritable feast in this area.
(music)
Timing is everything.
The lizards risk life and limb
to reach the precious food.
Eating as much as they can
before scuttling
back to safety.
(music)
Not only could
they be swept away,
but the cold waters mean the
lizard loses a lot of energy
retrieving a meal.
(music)
Each trip has to be countered
with moments of rest
in the sun.
But it's a fair trade-off
for food that can't run away.
The waters on the coast
of Chile are especially icy;
they come from a polar ocean.
(music)
The Humboldt Current is
several degrees colder
than the rest of the Pacific.
Strong winds drive this
slow, cold stream of water
up the western edge of Chile
from Antarctica.
The Humboldt reaches
600 miles wide
and is as deep as the seafloor.
The cold-water upwelling brings
with it nutrient-rich debris
from the seabed,
which phytoplankton thrive on.
And in turn, hundreds of
ocean animals come to feast
on the riches
of Chile's coastline.
(music)
With such an abundance
of water and food,
the Humboldt seems
to have nothing in common
with the desert
that runs alongside it.
But in fact, this current is
what makes the Atacama so dry.
(music)
The cold air above the Humboldt
acts as a vacuum
for airborne moisture.
(music)
Fog and mists hover as banks of
cloud over Chile's shoreline...
trapped by a collision
of air pressure.
(music)
But for a few hours every day,
warmer temperatures
release the fog,
and it moves up the cliffs
toward the desert,
warming into the edge
of the Atacama.
This is known
as the camanchaca.
Strong winds accompany
this fog phenomenon.
(music)
The desert is encased
in seconds.
For a few hours
nearly every day,
the fringes of the Atacama
are drenched in
fine water droplets.
It's a lifeline for animals and
plants on the edge of survival.
Here cactus flourish
in the path of the mists.
And are even covered
in water-loving lichen.
(music)
An oasis for
the Atacama's animals.
(music)
But the fog will last
only an hour or two,
so they must seize
the opportunity while it lasts.
(chirping)
The camanchaca entices
a surprising creature
out of hiding.
Hummingbirds are
usually only found
among forests and flowers.
But the daily fog makes life on
the edge of the desert possible
for the oasis hummingbird.
On Chile's coastline,
they capitalize on the riches
of the camanchaca.
Their long bills allow them
to extract nectar
from the flowering cacti.
Like most hummingbirds,
they have a high metabolism
and need to eat a lot of nectar
to survive.
These birds have a
'live fast, die young' policy.
Their long tongues are capable
of gathering nectar
at a rate of
20 licks per second.
(buzzing)
Almost as fast as their flying.
Their wings are a blur
as they beat almost
50 times per second.
With all this activity
their heart rate can exceed
1,000 beats per minute.
Without the camanchaca,
there's no way there
would be enough nectar
to fuel these tiny powerhouses.
These are true
desert opportunists.
The camanchaca's reach
isn't enough
to sustain animals and plants
further inland
in Chile's dry interior.
(wind blowing)
In these soils, even bacteria
struggle to survive.
(thunder)
Despite the odds,
every so often in the north,
the desert sees an event
nothing short of a miracle.
(music)
Seeds that have been dormant
for years erupt into life.
(music)
Fragile-looking flowers
fight their way
through the sandy soils.
(music)
The desert is alive
with a super bloom.
(music)
More than 200 species of plants
spring up
to remind Chile
of their existence.
This is a triumph
of resilience.
(music)
Aside from its beauty,
the flowering desert
is a banquet
for both beast and beetle.
A surprise windfall for
the animals of the Atacama.
(peeping)
Elsewhere in the desert, the
impact of rain feels different.
The soils of the Atacama aren't
well adapted for holding water.
They quickly become
overburdened,
triggering landslides
that completely reshape
the landscape.
For humans, the results
are catastrophic.
But for nature, these
landslides are regenerative.
(music)
Nutrients are churned up
and released,
and life thrives in their wake.
Water that soaks through
the desert to lowlands
easily carves a path
through the sand,
creating miniature canyons.
(music)
Hidden beneath the horizon,
these are ribbons of life
in a seemingly empty sand pit.
(music)
Hidden gullies conceal
a surprising resident.
They might look
out of place here,
but mountain parakeets thrive
in the Atacama Desert.
These feathery fluff balls
make this canyon a metropolis.
They're incredibly social birds
and spend all day together
in big, friendly groups.
(chirping)
They preen and chatter
to reinforce strong bonds.
(chirping)
But that doesn't mean
they don't have BFFs.
(chirping)
The reason behind
their bright green color
becomes obvious
when they stop to drink.
The mineral-rich water
carpets the canyon
in algae and grasses,
camouflaging
the green parakeets.
And airborne predators
just fly on by.
(chirping)
These narrow channels
are a surprising Eden
in a vast wilderness of dirt.
In the south of Chile's
Atacama Desert,
rains have a more obvious
effect in the landscape.
In a matter of days,
the dry yellows and browns
of the desert
are replaced by rich emerald.
(music)
This unexpected good fortune
for the animals of the Atacama
attracts visitors
to the fertile plains.
A South American gray fox
is here to hunt down a mate
for the first time in his life.
The desert can be
a lonely place,
and the drive to reproduce
is all-consuming.
(music)
He might have only one shot
at finding a mate this season,
so it's important
to be thorough.
A stranger to this area,
he makes his mark
on every surface available.
This scent trail is
the fox's version of a flag.
He's staking a claim
to the territory,
and access to
any females in it.
(music)
(sniffing)
It seems he's found a lead
on a local lady.
(shriek)
(barking)
He lets out a greeting.
(distant shrieking)
Out here, the sound
travels for miles.
(distant shriek)
(bark)
The female hears him.
Uncertain if he's a threat,
she's cautious.
(shriek)
(distant shriek)
She provides him
with a coded message.
(music)
Her urine reveals
her reproductive status.
It's the beginning
courtship proceedings.
(music)
(sniffing)
Finally, he tracks her down.
Before he can approach,
he demonstrates submission,
so she understands
his intentions.
But he's a little overeager,
and she's not making it easy.
Wrapping her tail around her
body is her way of denying him.
He'll have to try
harder than this
if he wants to win her over.
(music)
It's going to be
an exhausting few days.
If he forgets
to pay attention to her,
she has ways of reminding him
to up his game.
(music)
This pair will remain together
for five more months
before they go
their separate ways.
In that time, with any luck,
they'll leave behind a legacy
in the form of
up to four offspring.
(shriek)
The rains have provided
a temporary relief
from desolate dust lands.
But there are many places
in the Atacama
that have no hope of seeing
water falling from the sky.
Instead, life here
has to source moisture
from the ground.
But that's easier
said than done.
The Salar de Pintados
is an ancient lakebed.
The soil has extremely high
concentrations of salt.
It's nearly impossible
for anything to grow,
much less live.
(music)
Plants that survive here
have learned to adapt
over thousands of years.
As a result, more than 60% of
the flora found in the Atacama
is found nowhere else on Earth.
In this dry wasteland,
the tamarugo tree is an island
of life in a sea of salt.
(music)
A magnet for all manner
of creatures.
(music)
In the blazing sun, the inside
of the tamarugo's canopy
is a sanctuary from the heat.
For ancient nomads
crossing the desert,
this would have been the only
natural shelter for miles.
And in the right season,
the tree even bears
a protein-rich fruit.
The secret of this seemingly
miracle tree lies underground.
Deep, thick roots
tap into the water table,
sucking up moisture
trapped in the earth.
Remnants of rainwater
filtered from the Andes.
(music)
Remarkably, the tamarugo
has a modest ancestor.
This is a flowering member
of the pea family,
an unlikely master
of the desert.
The Atacama is an unforgiving
realm of Chilean wilderness.
The desert covers more than
10% of the entire country.
(music)
Dictating hardships
for every living creature
that dares to exist
within its borders.
(music)
The animals of the Atacama
are enterprising risk-takers,
defending opportunity and
resources at every turn.
Their lives depend on it.
Only those that dare
survive Chile's borderlands.
(music)